[Musik]
die staats und regierungschefs der g 7
haben schloss elmau wieder verlassen
einige wie us-präsident beiden sind
direkt weitergereist zum nächsten gipfel
dem der nato in madrid wenn sie gleich
anknüpfen können an das thema das in den
bayerischen alpen alle anderen in den
schatten stellte der ukraine krieg und
seine weltweiten auswirkungen
der ukraine helfen so lange es nötig ist
auch nach kriegsende
das war die kernbotschaft der g7 und
damit herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf
spezial ein letztes mal vor der kulisse
des wettersteingebirge
wir wollen bilanz ziehen was hat der
gipfel gebracht und haben dazu ein
ausführliches gespräch mit kanzler
scholz geführt zunächst aber fasst
thomas reichert die drei tage von ellmau
zusammen die server mit den parketts
erzählt schon mal viel über dieses
g7-treffen herr ein paar sitzungen
reicht es wenn zb frankreichs präsident
makro is auszieht
großbritanniens premier chance und
findet dann auch er müsse sei es
ausziehen der chef der weltbank macht
gleich mit und kann er das premier toto
sowieso ebenso der präsident des senegal
beim ersten treffen dagegen blieben die
jacketts noch brav an
wir alle müssen zeigen dass wir härter
sind als putin kann johnson dann noch
vielleicht aber mussten sie sich das
zuerst vor allem gegenseitig zeigen
wenn die g 7 am ende eines erreicht
haben immer dann ist es eine in den
maßstäben der politik erstaunliche
vertrautheit und nähe
erschoss denn heute mittag zur
abschließenden pressekonferenz
marschiert hat er ein gipfel hinter sich
bei dem der westen wegen putins
bedrohungen enger zusammengerückt ist
als lange zuvor uns allen ist klar dass
es kein zurück geben kann und wirkst du
derzeit vor diesen krieg und seine ist
auch klar
vor uns liegt eine zeit der unsicherheit
dies herausfordernd und darum sind
entschlossenheit und geschlossenheit
ebenso wichtig ukraine ist präsident
seelands geht er gestern per
videokonferenz zugeschaltet ist
versprechen die g7 budget hilfen über
29,5 milliarden dollar außerdem weitere
waffenlieferungen so lange wie nötig
sollen die sanktionen gegen russland in
kraft bleiben und es soll eine
internationale wiederaufbau-konferenz
für die ukraine geben und max schubert
wir wollen sicherstellen dass wir bereit
sind der ukraine die art von
zusicherungen zu geben die sie für ihre
zukunft in bezug auf die lieferung von
waffen auf nato niveau aus bildung und
aufklärung benötigen damit die ukraine
nicht wieder angriffen das kann
die gäste sind bei diesem gipfel fast
noch wichtiger als die g7 selbst in
denen zb das geherzt und umarmt wird
gesucht sind verbündete gegen putin und
gegenargumente zu putins propaganda die
sanktionen des westens seien schuld an
der sich verschärfenden globalen
ernährungskrise
4,5 milliarden dollar versprechen die g7
zu hungerhilfe und halten weiter fest am
schutz des klimas trotz der energiekrise
das ist ein notfall aber niemand hat auf
diesem gipfel den willen geäußert dass
dieser notfall ein abweichen von unseren
klimaziele rechtfertigen kann oder
rechtfertigen wird
joe biden hat mit seinen vorschlägen auf
dem gipfel weniger erfolg auf einen
importstopp für russisches gold oder
eine preisobergrenze für russisches öl
können sich die g7 erstmal nicht
verständigen ganz so weit geht die große
einigkeit doch nicht
beiden fährt heute dann schon früher als
alle anderen los vom g7 zum nato gipfel
in madrid wo die meisten sich und all
die offenen fragen wieder sehen werden
und
direkt nach abschluss des gipfels hatte
ich gelegenheit bundeskanzler scholz in
schloss elmau nach seiner g7 bilanz zu
fragen
herr bundeskanzler das ist ihr erster
g7-gipfel im amt und das gleich als
gastgeber sozusagen in der poleposition
was hatten sie sich vorgenommen und
welches ergebnis ist ihnen besonders
wichtig ich wollte dass sich die staaten
hier zusammenkommen die sieben großen
wirtschaftsstarken demokratien aber auch
die gäste die wir eingeladen haben aus
indonesien aus indien aus südafrika
senegal und argentinien unterhaken dass
wir auf augenhöhe mit der handel
diskutieren auch ein bisschen informell
also ohne krawatte und manchmal auch
ohne anzugjacke und wirklich dinge
miteinander
vertrauensvoll erarbeiten das ist
gelungen ich glaube kann mir sagen hier
haben sich die g7 geeint gezeigt und
stehen zusammen und das gilt auch
natürlich für diejenigen die wir noch
als gäste hatten mit dem wir auch
gemeinsame politik entwickeln können so
dass die demokratien der welt nicht in
gespalten sind im westen und den rest
wie sich das manchmal herr putin
vorstellt über dem gipfel ort hier gab
es immer wieder mal dunkle
gewitterwolken deshalb stehen wir auch
hier drinnen und nicht vor dem schönen
alpenpanorama aber vor allem war auch
sehr präsent die dunkle wolke des
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
ukraine der ukrainische präsident waren
zugeschaltet per video unterhalten hat
noch mal dringend unterstützung
angefordert oder erbeten ich fand die
begründung dabei aber interessant so das
sagen in den krieg noch vor dem winter
zu beenden sie sprechen von einer sehr
langen strecke auf die man sich
einstellen müssen
ist das eine andere lage beurteilen
es geht hier nicht um lage beurteilt es
geht darum das zu tun was zu tun ist und
das haben wir als zugesagt aber und auch
gemeinsam vorgenommen gehabt nämlich
dass es weiter so gehen wird dass wir
finanzielle hilfe leisten für die
ukraine das wir humanitäre hilfe leisten
und dass wir dem kann ich nur
unterstützen mit waffenlieferung das
turnier sehr viele staaten in der welt
deutschlands zu sehen ein vorne dabei
und gleichzeitig ist es so dass wir
auch sehr viele sehr präzise sanktionen
gegen russland verhängt haben die dazu
beitragen sollen dass russland von
diesem krieg ab lässt den brutal ist
mörderisch und unglaublich viel zerstört
und deshalb muss das unsere gemeinsame
anstrengungen seien trotzdem die
nachfrage halten sie die perspektive
kriegsende vor dem winter für
realistisch das ist schwer zu beurteilen
weil das sich ja auch von vielen vielen
anderen fragen heraus beurteilen dass
die sich gar nicht beantworten lassen
heute und deshalb finde ich muss man
sich eben doch auf das konzentrieren was
man wirklich tun kann und das ist unsere
unterstützung sie haben das stichwort
sanktionen schon genannt jetzt gab es
hier kein riesiges sanktionspaket gegen
russland aber gezielte sanktionen gegen
die russische rüstungsindustrie
schauen wir mal auf die wirksamkeit der
bisherigen da sieht man ja dass die
russischen kriegskassen und staatskassen
gefühlt gefüllt werden eben weil die
energiepreise hoch sind und länder wie
indien und china mehr abnehmen verlaufen
so die sanktionen ins leere wir wissen
dass die russische wirtschaft erheblich
getroffen ist von den sanktionen die wir
auf den weg gebracht haben das wird wenn
sie sehr lange wirksam bleiben auch sich
immer weiter verstärken kein land der
welt und schon gar nicht eines das
selber nicht technologisch mit an der
spitze steht kann es lange aushalten von
den technischen fortschritt die welt
ausgeschlossen zu sein genau das
passiert was land gerade es wird also
sehr schnell viele jahrzehnte
zurückgeworfen das den eigenen
lebensstandard was die technologischen
möglichkeiten betrifft gilt übrigens
auch für die rüstung die russland selber
produziert und gleichzeitig haben unsere
sanktionen auch dazu geführt dass
russland sich von dem geld einen namen
die es hat nichts kaufen kann weil wir
eben auch export sanktionen gerade was
high tech güter und vieles andere
betrifft verhängt haben das macht sich
jetzt auch jeden tag dort will
der amerikanische präsident joe biden
hat ja im vorfeld dieses gipfels schon
vorgeschlagen den ölpreis zu deckeln für
russisches öl das klingt ja erstmal nach
einer guten idee scheint aber nicht
konsensfähig so einfach wir haben uns
darauf verständigt diese komplizierten
bedingungen dafür bitten an der
entwicklung und klaus europa hat ja
selbst eine entscheidung getroffen die
darauf hinausläuft dass wir
importe aus russland weitgehend
reduzieren um 90 bis zum jahresende
und das ist ja etwas was auch schon ein
beitrag leistet trotzdem das ist eine
sehr interessante idee die aber von
vielen voraussetzungen abhängt und
gerade deshalb wollen wir uns das
gemeinsam schon eine schwierige frage
für sie und die bundesregierung wird ja
auch sein wie redet man nach mit putin
trifft man ihn und die der frage kann
man in diesem jahr gar nicht ausweichen
weil auch g20 noch anstehen zu dem er
eingeladen ist was spricht denn dafür
mit jemandem zu sprechen
der letztlich ein kriegsverbrecher ist
zunächst mal muss mit der russischen
regierung gesprochen werden das tun
viele ich habe das auch getan der
französische präsident hat das getan
viele andere aber auch von denen die
hier zusammen gekommen sind und wichtig
ist dass wir wenn es um die
formate der zusammenarbeit in der welt
geht die auch für die zukunft erhalten
das geld für unser zusammen kampf als
wirtschaftsstarke demokratien das geld
da war für die zusammenkunft der 20
staaten die sich getarnt sich nennen da
es dieses jahr indonesien das
präsidentschafts land nächstes jahr wird
es indien seien zwei länder mit denen
wir hier sehr gute gespräche geführt
haben werden es gipfelt weil sie als
große demokratien des globalen südens
wichtige partner von uns sind und
deshalb ist die verabredung hier unter
den bedingungen wie wir sie heute
verstehen können dass wir das g20-format
erhalten wollen und deshalb auch nicht
vorhaben durch wegbleiben das kaputt zu
machen aber wir wollen natürlich unsere
ziele umsetzen und das zur sprache
bringen was wir zur sprache bringen
müssen da geht es auch um die weltweiten
auswirkungen des fruchtbaren russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine viele
länder spüren dass der jetzt histone
hungerkatastrophen die energiepreise
steigen nicht nur bei uns und in der
ganzen welt und manche länder haben dann
kaum noch möglichkeiten das zu bezahlen
was sie brauchen da würde ich gerne
nachfragen denn genau diese kriegs folge
die der mangel an lebensmittelversorgung
weltweit ist natürlich ein riesen
problem und es drohen auch hungersnöte
wenn das weiter so geht wie ein
ukrainisches getreide getreide blockiert
in den silos liegt was haben sie konkret
hier beschlossen und was dagegen zu tun
wir haben eine internationale allianz
geschmiedet gegen die hungerkatastrophe
das werden wir auch weiter tun und dann
wird es auch finanzielle mittel gehen
die wir bereitstellen damit wir
verhindern dass menschen nicht zu essen
haben das ist ja dass für einige hundert
millionen jetzt als gefahr droht und
gleichzeitig bemühen wir uns zusammen
mit dem generalsekretär der vereinten
nationen dass die exporte des getreides
das in der ukraine lagert noch möglich
werden und der ist da wirklich aktiv und
versucht alles das möglich zu machen und
ein bisschen sieht es so aus als ob es
sogar vielleicht gelingen könnte zum
schluss noch die frage herr
bundeskanzler was ist ihre persönliche
bilanz dieses gipfels ihren es ist gut
mit freunden zusammen zu sein und das
sind hier freunde die länder die
staatschefs und die regierung die hier
versammelt waren das hat sich als gut
erwiesen so viel zeit miteinander zu
haben politik beruht auch auf vertrauen
dieses vertrauen ist da und wir haben
wirklich sehr viele sehr konkrete dinge
entschieden die auch der welt weiter
helfen und das ist auch gut scholz
vielen dank für das gespräch
das gespräch haben wir am nachmittag
aufgezeichnet
gleich nach dem g7 gipfel hier in ellmau
hat in madrid der nato gipfel begonnen
us-präsident beiden war der erste der
von ellmau nach spanien gereist ist dort
wird er auf den türkischen präsidenten
erdogan treffen bei den gesprächen soll
es um kampfjets der usa gehen um die
sich die türkei schon länger bemüht aber
auch um den geplanten nato-beitritt
finnlands und schwedens wer von der
türkei bisher blockiert wird und
im studio begrüße ich sarah tagung von
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik guten amt genannt ich
glaube man kann schon sagen von ellmau
geht ein zeichen der geschlossenheit aus
die nato wird sich ähnliches wünschen
könnte das am türkischen präsidenten
erdogan scheitern also in jedem fall ist
es gut möglich dass erdogan den beitritt
von vier schweden und finnland zu nato
weiter verzögern wird um den preis
hochzutreiben
nichtsdestotrotz den ja auch einige
andere sachen auf der agenda die
aufstockung der schnellen eingreiftruppe
auf 300.000 man also wirklich eine
erhebliche vergrößerung und auch die
annahme des neuen strategiekonzept und
ich glaube damit kann man auch schon ein
signal aussenden aus wenn möglicherweise
dabei tritt noch länger auf sich warten
lässt die usa haben angekündigt ihre
militärische präsenz in europa dauerhaft
zu verstärken fallen wir da gerade
zurück in die muster des kalten krieges
also was wir in jedem fall beobachten
können und dass er schon seit einigen
jahren ist eine verstärkte militärische
präsidenten nicht nur auf seiten der
nato sondern auch auf seiten russlands
russland hat ja gerade angekündigt
belarus nuklear auszustatten als müssen
die biografie kriegen raketen und
flugzeugen das ist etwas was man
beobachten muss wo es militärisch
kontakte brauchtum unbeabsichtigt der
eskalation zu vermeiden und risiken zu
verringern die union also cdu csu
verlangen mehr waffen für die ukraine
kanzler stolz und andere waren vor einer
direkten konfrontation nato weißrussland
wie weit können wir da eigentlich gehen
ohne selbst hineingezogen zu werden in
diesen krieg also die ganz klare grenze
ist die beteiligung von soldaten und
soldatinnen der nato also beispielsweise
bei der umsetzung einer verbotszone die
diskussion unter den unterschied
zwischen leichten werfen schweren waffen
oder auch schützenpanzern kampfpanzern
ist nicht das ausschlaggebende
vielen dank zara paragon für das
gespräch und für die vielen anderen in
diesen tagen hier in ellmau herzlichen
dank sehr gerne
zu wenig militärhilfe für die ukraine zu
spät die milliarden zusagen für arme
länder zu vage die vereinbarungen in
sachen klimawandel so die kritik von
opposition
hilfsorganisationen und klimaschützern
zu den beschlüssen der g 7 tatsächlich
klingen nach jedem gipfel die
abschlusserklärungen vollmundig später
zeigt sich immer wieder gemachte zusagen
und versprechen werden nicht eingehalten
oder geraten in vergessenheit
wie nachhaltig wird der zweite elmar
gipfel sein matthias kubitz mit
reaktionen auf die gipfelergebnisse
gipfel wieder weg was bleibt übrig vom
gigantischen berg treffen neben lassen
zelten der gegner briefmarken für
sammler und dem kreativ christen logo
vielleicht führt heimatmuseum auch
kritik an dem g7 beschlüssen während die
mächtigen heute die bayerischen berge
hinter sich lassen ziehen auch die
kameras weiter zur opposition
ich muss schon sagen dass wenn die
sieben reichsten staaten dieser welt
sich darauf verständigen die hungerhilfe
um 4,5 milliarden aufzustocken dann ist
das wirklich ein schlechter witz also
zur erinnerung allein in deutschland
steckt gerade 100 milliarden in die
bundeswehr haben die g7 die richtigen
entscheidungen für ein ende der
erderwärmung betroffen nein meint ray
disc futures der bundeskanzler hat mit
den g7 eines der großen versprechen der
letzten un klimakonferenz gebrochen nun
wird man doch neue gas projekte im
ausland fördern twittert luisa neubauer
und das versprechen die ukraine massiver
zu bewaffnen und das land militärisch zu
unterstützen so lange wie nötig
überfällig findet die union falsch sagt
die afd
das sollte zeichen gesetzt werden dass
verhandelt werden soll und dass es nicht
eine eskalationsspirale gibt ihren ende
kein mensch absehen kann ich befürchte
wir stehen erst am anfang dessen was uns
deutschen auch wirtschaftlich blüht
deshalb hätte ich mir ein bisschen mehr
zurückhaltung gewünscht russland macht
geländegewinne die ukraine ist kaum in
der lage mal territorium zurück zu
erobern die ukraine braucht mehr
militärische unterstützung eindeutig ja
innenpolitische reaktionen abseits es
gibt und wie reagiert der g7 gegner
nummer eins auch angesichts der nato auf
rüstungs pläne aus moskau heißt es heute
man entwickle maßnahmen zur stärkung der
russischen westgrenze
und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt roderich
kiesewetter
außenpolitischer experte von cdu/csu
guten abend und
am treffen der ukraine soll solange
geholfen werden wie es nötig ist heißt
es hier doch im moment kann niemand
vorhersagen wie lange dieser krieg
eigentlich dauert was genau ist also die
botschaft
wir uns von ich sag mal ist das ein sehr
erfolgreicher gipfel auch für unser land
da ist uns auch als union sehr daran
gelegen entscheidend ist aber wie es mit
der ukraine weiter geht und hier müssen
wir uns auf einen wirklich langjährigen
abnutzungskrieg einstellen es sei denn
wir liefern jetzt sehr rasch massiv
waffen bis dahin dass die ukraine ihre
souveränität wieder herstellen kann in
den grenzen vom januar aber es ist
besser und klüger sich auf einen langen
abnutzungskrieg einzustellen und dann
sehr sorgsam sorgfältig und überlegt die
waffenlieferung zu planen und erreichen
eben nicht mehr vier maß oder drei maß
und sieben panzerhaubitzen da geht es um
ganz andere stückzahlen oder müssen wir
auch unsere bevölkerung darauf
vorbereiten ihr parteivorsitzender
friedrich merz hat genau das gefordert
mehr waffen für die ukraine laufen wir
da nicht irgendwann gefahr selbst
reinzurutschen in diesem krieg
nun ich denke dass die ampelkoalition
ist ja selbst auch fordert sogar frau
strack zimmermann hat nochmals sehr
nachdrücklich gestern die forderung nach
lieferung von dutzenden marder und die
er sofort verfügbar sind geäußert die
gefahr selbst kriegspartei zu werden sie
ich nicht frau tagung hat dass er eben
auch sehr gut geschildert wir könnten
sogar von dem völkerrecht hier dürften
ja sogar deutlich mehr tun aber die
nukleare abschreckung wirkt von russland
und deshalb sind ihr mit
waffenlieferungen gut beraten und hier
kommt es darauf an wirklich auch in
großer stückzahl mal dazu liefern wir
liefern 15 gepard marder sind viel
leichter bewaffnet und sind in viel
größerer stückzahl verfügbar
wir können nur sagen wo es geht es wäre
sinnvoll
präsident see lenski warnt vor einer
schwierigen lage wenn der krieg nicht
vor dem winter beendet ist das wiederum
halten viele beobachter für
unrealistisch sie offenkundig ja auch
sie haben gerade gesprochen von einem
langen abnutzungskrieg muss sich die
ukraine nicht doch auf einer
verhandlungslösung und mögliche
gebietsverluste einstellen
zu verhandlungsbeginn gehören zwei der
bundeskanzler hat eben selbst deutlich
gemacht dass putin überhaupt nicht
bereit ist zu verhandeln aber ich möchte
einen anderen gedanken noch einbringen
selensky ist der ausdruck der sehnsucht
der ukrainischen bevölkerung eine
korruptionsfreie regierung zu haben und
er hat diesen anspruch in vielen jahren
sehr harter mühsamer arbeit ist eher
gerecht geworden wenn wir ihnen nicht so
unterstützen dass es ihm gelingt dir
seine souveränität des landes wieder
herzustellen dann wird er von noch
lebenden oligarchen abgelöst und dann
werden wir ein anderes regime an der
führung der ukraine haben deswegen
sollten der seine worte sehr ernst
nehmen und alles tun dass es ihm gelingt
als präsident frei gewählt der präsident
der ukraine alles zu tun die
souveränität der ukraine wieder
herzustellen das geht mit geld aber vor
allen dingen mit waffen us präsident joe
biden dankte ja schon am ersten abend
kanzler scholz geradezu demonstrativ
dafür wie entschlossen er sich von
anfang an gegen putin gestellt habe sie
in amerika und deutschland aus ihrer
sicht jetzt tatsächlich an einem strang
nun beiden ist innenpolitisch extrem
unter druck hat die vorwahlen im herbst
und in zwei jahren
präsidentschaftswahlen hier gilt es
natürlich auch transatlantisch die
amerikaner zu unterstützen und das war
ein werben dafür so verstehe ich beiden
und meine transatlantischen freunde mit
denen ich im engen kontakt bin dass
deutschland mehr tut damit er auch sagen
kann seinen amerikanischen wählerinnen
und wähler in europa hat standen
deutschland hat verstanden sie
unterstützen uns und nehmen die
ukrainische herausforderung ernst die
amerikaner unterstützen zehn mal mehr
die ukraine ist wie es tun vielen dank
für das gespräch herr kiesewetter
ist ja gerne vorne
der gipfel in ellmau ist vorbei vieles
ist diskutiert manches beschlossen
worden jetzt müssen es alle nur noch
umsetzen es gab proteste friedlich fast
immer eingegrenzt und bewacht allerdings
bis an die schmerzgrenze und darüber
hinaus safety first eben es war ein
treffen unter freunden das vertrauen
geschaffen hat so sieht es der kanzler
vielen dank für ihr interesse zum
abschluss schauen wir noch mal auf die
bilder des gipfels von denen einige in
erinnerung bleiben werden auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
die latte